I read that you fell in love with the
idea of space and space exploration when
you were five watching Neil Armstrong
walking on the moon so let me uh ask you
to look back at the historical context
and impact of that so the space race
from 1957 to
1969 between the Soviet Union and the US
was in many ways epic it was um a rapid
sequence of dramatic events for
satellite to space first human to space
first space walk first un crude landing
on the moon then some failures
explosions deaths on both sides actually
and then the first human walking on the
moon uh what are some of the more
inspiring moments or insights you take
away from that time those few years that
just uh 12 years well I mean there's so
much inspiring there um you know one of
the great things to take away from that
one of the great Von Brown quotes is I
have
uh I have come to use the word
impossible with great
caution yeah yeah and so that's kind of
the big story of Apollo is that things
you know the uh going to the moon was
literally an analogy that people used
for something that's impossible you know
oh yeah you'll do that when when you
know men walk on the Moon Yeah and of
course it finally happened um so you
know I think it was pulled forward in
time because of the Space Race I think
you know with the geopolitical
implications and you know how much
resource was put into it you know at the
peak that program was spending you know
two or 3% of
GDP uh on the Apollo program so much
resource I think it was pulled forward
in time you know we kind of did it ahead
of when we quote unquote should have
done it yeah um and so in that way it's
also a technical Marvel I mean it's
truly incredible it's uh you know it's
the 20th century version of building the
pyramids or something it's you know it's
an achievement that um because it was
pulled forward in time and because it
did something that had previously been
thought impossible it rightly deserves
its place as you know in the pantheon of
great human
achievements